the evacuation first we don't expect any
far along tonight should be fairly quiet
about doing please think building by the
nearest available exit key chamber
our 70.3 in the public car park in the
better side of the Civic suite please do
not delay your evacuation but any lines
given permission to do by the council
staff please know that this meeting will
be recorded and can we make sure our
funds were either turned off or on the
side
thank you qualities flight suits I have
councillor Smith and he's been
substituted by my trouthe skill and
counseling 16 Hawaii is substituted by
it comes up mrs. C - at ease boys 19
absolute but she's up to this but
because you will not be able to say no
miss attending
okay tell me approve the minutes of the
meeting held on your 20th of June 2008
thank you to receive that Corrections
thank you thank you're pretty surprised
from the lead officer Hospital Academy
quite like this she's no microphone
disclosable big you reading interest on
the counter we have on T the bank
respond to the development we are
allowed to speak the risking members but
then we have to leave the room
once the debate starts
we're here tonight for planning motive
on 1800 once request for Iain Glen
between Avenue Malins
line and local bridge thank you Jim
this application scientist to
familiarize members relates to the site
of aliens farm there on western edge of
Polebridge formerly a quite new some
grazing land that we did out here the
Ptolemaic science if we can jump to the
ER location their chairman is the
applications extract from your local
plan the allocations plan members recall
that this release that area of land in
the two shades from the green belts and
this is an adopted current document just
took that land as an extension of the
existing the whole bridge settlement if
you could jump to the at my concept
members will see from the history set
out in the report that the planning
permission was granted in an outline to
the area edge ridge you'll see from the
allocation that's the previous slide as
a pocket of a couple of parcels of land
up there which are part of the release
but they're not part of this application
cycle did consent
in fact they work in addition so so this
animation that was wrongfully now I did
not include both articles in the top
north west corner we can jump to the
density plan chairman this was a an
indication plan in the archive agreement
out my side where it showed the upper
portions on to Windermere Avenue would
be probably and say two-story and a
relatively lower density with the rest
of the site mixture of densities and
Heights but particularly a central part
would be allowable up to three stories
so three stories in the outline get
permits an element or designs a three
story and that outlying percent if we
can jump to the current application site
then please Rob members this is the
application that's before we knew
tonight in detail or reserve matters it
networks as the second half of a
permission when you have an outline
grant it's the first half and then these
kindly reserved matters of these details
they come along as a second half making
a complete whole you know permission
you'll see that it shows a detail by at
the site broadly following the
parameters that were laid down by the
outline excludes the past of the land at
the top that I was referring to and
you'll see it also excludes this site
here there's a moment bungalow standing
in the middle of the site these are
parts of the application site unusually
perhaps it goes round the development
proposed goes around
the tiny bungalow you'll also see a
traditional farmhouse building there
that they depart for the application
site itself so there's two buildings
retaining the existing moment over which
all the development goes round and the
town house which is part of to buy out
the considerations now just off the base
of the map being accessed comes in off
hull breach Road the access has already
been reading out night stage the access
elements in this application and the
various plots and the minutia that come
through the student as a whole the
development is based around three
character areas and parkland and
parkland quarter of this lower part of
the site moving on to another village
call in the middle higher density and
then at the top what is called as the
northern quarter you'll see from the
outline and they were so included in
this there's an access to Malians line
that would serve a site in permeability
for vehicles into the settlement that is
also a number of points where the Destry
and cycle axis could also enter the
development if we can jump to the street
scene IV please run members will say
that this top view here is a view that
this section of the public water on the
present shaped art of the road then we
moved to this bottom view which is taken
to this part slightly different setting
at least as you see on the page layout
and this bottom image is a view looking
there doubtless onto the buffer strip
between existing development and the
edge of the post jump to the second
stream
this one shows two of the fatted
buildings in this part here then we move
to another view that's showing through
here and then these large boom of these
views here going looking on the outside
you jump to the visualization please
rope members will see that the image
this would be on entry into the side
compartment was the bikes this is coming
in off whole bridge road this is an
artist impression and how as you enter
the development the sphere would look
now a concern that we have is that you
asked you to note because we will turn
back in moments of the layout back it
just take a minute of notes and pause on
the gaps between these buildings here
nicely attached perhaps in some
circumstances lots of off street parking
and garages you'll have seen from the
officer report there is concern on that
you know an environmental / design
context even this present officer
tremendous opportunity to get a
attractive built frontage do maintaining
parking designs and standards and
getting the vehicles off street but in
urban designer terms these gets you
largely avoid in english setting now if
we can go back to the layout please Rob
no I'm sorry
absolutely drop to the bottom message
press I know if you can zoom in a bit on
the bottom part
there's probably worth the members
noting that we get the same sprite these
these are for instance three [ __ ]
weeks and in a larger garage at the back
and all of these doubles it's a great
shine that that gavage through them
nicely detached as they might be in some
preferences but he found planning in an
urban design sensitive it's a great
opportunity to play something really
attractive a lot better than this so the
extend the offices feel that the
application is you're being refused
that's not the sole reason just why
we're on that detail that's that's one
of the features that lead to the
recommendation if you have now there are
other issues about the extensive color
dominated layouts like we see here and
then you would have seen that in the
body report there are two comments from
the encounters over and designed quite
extensive comments that shows that
there's a lot of criticism that firstly
didn't result in a conclusion the
officers read into that that there was
definite concerns and asked comedies
accounting to clarify that so they
brought forth they a second comments
that's also before you in the police and
again is very critical but concluded
actually that there was no objection now
we've had further discussions with our
colleagues on these points and a
confident that the recommendation we
brought to you
on the report papers that you've seen it
amounts to objections on the urban
designers number of criticisms in other
buildings that back at detailing those
and then the fundamental reason that the
character we saw her on those street
views and I accept they are isolated
viewers of plants of development it's
very difficult actually to tell one
street from another and what they're
really needs in this case for those
character areas that the Parkland courts
of the village court and the northern
water to be reinforced by better
architectural detailing between those
different areas otherwise what you get
is a massive house in some five hundred
houses that broadly look the site you
will take a few different colored bricks
and times okay so there is a what I
haven't mentioned probably one of the
best landscaping scenes through this
okay but we think that the developer is
rather relied on the landscaping to
achieve the character works we're saying
you need the design of the buildings to
complement your seals so the second
strand in the recommendation you had was
to do international space pandas
appendix one to your report cites at
some forty three percent of the
buildings were post would not
the criteria to floor spaces covered
areas size of some of the bedrooms and
offices such a significant pilot cannot
accept me that chortle now we saw when
the report on the agenda was published
that's there was the recommendation to
refuse if we have also today he received
a letter from the whole Business
Association is several pages some seat
pages to this but if I just give you the
highlights points that the first point
they feel that the infrastructure issues
are paramount and good reasons for
refusal and that we agree weekly Council
recommendation that this faxes published
offices and that those reasons are
holding the in planning law they agreed
with the urban designers comments that
I've alluded to and general mayhem that
substance and it should be alternative
options there are outstanding conditions
awaiting discharge on a design brief at
that point actually chairman does not
stop the applicant bringing the whole
site over Steve what you see before you
tonight the purpose of that condition of
those two conditions right the site up
Queens advice is to sell a lot of
different developers and those
developers come back on into doing their
own thing there needs to be a
consistency in architectural treatment
whether they're given license to be
number two imaginative but consistency
together and that's the purpose of those
conditions for a large application given
the live among about you perhaps don't
need them if you look hotter scheme what
it would look like use one point one
point the Association says that they
suggest there should be security screen
around these issues with excited to
protect the ability and they ask the
question to clarify claims remain as
two-story dwellings under the lifetime
homes criterion they acknowledge that
oh no longer parts of planning these
within building rates they also consume
the Ordnance Survey site boundary that
they cite that part of the site is
within roar a--the and the remaining
them within whole and that should be
distinct in the lighthouse they consider
that the scheme is over the development
especially small none they also state
concerning the road this is not me it's
designer guide and frontages are on the
middle ten meters
they said sewage connections between old
and new collection dispersal criteria
should be clarified they question what
plans to the improvement of water for
babies as well that's lovely evening
remix of the outline Bhushan and any
discharge of conditions is be substation
in this layout to submitting to us the
off-site stuff for me they suggest and
they ask that how little adoptive rights
and the dodgy drivers family properties
when we safeguarded against disruptive
in the progressive construction place
and there any guarantees given to as
they say that some fourteen hundred and
seventy five properties would be
affected by that you know
five to six years expressed concerns at
the hazardous nature of the existing in
telecommunications masters they
understand from the applicants located
elsewhere the objects to three-story
buildings they've got a totally
unacceptable separating the village this
part of the developments they say that
the parking provision is in that it was
not enough visitor parking they say that
the Roman frontages contributing the 45
degree rule for overshadowing and
denominating requirements of the AC
design guide and the majority of
affordable housing had promised with
carpark against the highway boundary
which they say caused an insufficient
intact they asked where the malleus Lane
will be used for traffic Russell around
the balcony being instructed to take to
the entrance to the site the ground
working activity in short major
destruction and they asked the what
activities minimize the surface water
flooding
without water disposal topologies and
innovation tanks they believe a contract
manager best place to deal with personal
issues they ask the details of the
adoption agreement to do with angular
walls of the found right niche and the
catchment area of a design and
assessment the details of the
archaeological or the archeological base
emotions to help members we have had
details that's that's discharge of
conditions to the planning and
production regard to fund risk they
argue that the developer must
demonstrate that they have arranged
approval before any environment works
occurring out and then the sector state
must be notified of the fun business
system in science which you noted the
beach were affected by tightly mocking
as the apple of reach
being affected by tidal surges the
original buffer zones were to have
underground the Technovation tanks but I
say the layout of the landscaping now
shows above throughout the Technovation
basins member would have seen in the
past that the use of those areas when
they're dry as open recreational space
usually accept it what happens to those
basins
there is excessive right then they fill
because they're relatively shallow
amounting 24 to activate of why in dry
periods and an acceptable right where
they don't go through the system they
criticize the garden areas the question
whether the layout complies with the
council standards and the inadequacy of
the firefighting positions in the
private access right lastly the front
end advices for two and a half stories
let me show proposed flat roof dormers
which they say is country to the council
policy now to help members me that
members would have seen them
particularly delegated applications we
get for impeached room doors or fragment
doors if you has to be taken on the
character of the street where you were
seen in our reports on dating
where there are streets with quite a
strong element of that were in front
always be unreasonable for a council to
refuse a patron or to insist on pastry
perhaps wouldn't stop an applicant
wishing to put the truth in it is all
down to whether it's reasonable given
the presence of strong character of that
many donors insisted to impose that
picture of design because that's your
guidance and our policy in this case in
this light out developers creating there
is a character of buildings by community
origins that are characteristically
approved doors the members will also see
from the addendum of each other but
there are standing comments from the
Polish parish council which I visited
there there is the comics association
and also building brings me to change
which follows the publication of the
office so reports of a recommendation
will be had to refuse and the applicants
met with us on Tuesday this week and
they have asked for a deferment so that
Bacon's
alternative plans to us to address the
urban designers
might have gone through in this
presentation you'll also see that the
second strand of officers concerns that
amounted to refusal which is on the
National Space Center's the applicants
provided witnessed agility after only a
count sales opinion a barristers opinion
that suggests that the substance of that
is misplaced and that no grounds and
refusing on that line now people that
we've had that on the choose that there
isn't time officers gear to go to
consider that and report that to have
our view prior to that clearly set out
that it would be prudent to give the
applicant time you guys significant time
to revise the urban design issues there
are officers to go away and research the
validity of the applicants fighting army
the sliced Angus and today the
recommendation is that members defer the
application to allow us to receive the
revisions from the applicant consultant
consider our motors and also to consider
the point made by the applicants with
regard to the issues in their view our
current share by officers on how their
space standards being applied that's the
new gem
we have to at the end
[Music]
we're also really good proposal for the
district has to consider with respect to
the section 106 agreement regarding the
year
furthermore with her consultations with
residents here the plans to provide us
with their comments which we as members
took into consideration before
formalizing our decision and response
unfortunately our original response was
not included within the report submitted
to the development committee but now
that they are now part of the tandem in
that report it does not include new and
requires material information therefore
we would write the development committee
to consider that the reserve practice is
deferred to a later date so allowed it's
time for revisions to be made with input
from all the parties including ourselves
Thank You chairman thank you very much
and it's speaker we've got is mr. a
mountain through bonds head planning
things
I have five minutes
thank you madam chair and thank you to
the opportunity to speak this evening
good evening members of the public by a
miss Raine absent and planning as bad
edibles and homes Eastern Counties based
in transferred as stated in the offices
report the principle of development in
to establish refinement drives this CG
big fairway location totals and homes
owns the site of this allocation the
application is the culmination of a
detailed discussion with planning design
landscaping highways and members of the
and other stakeholders including members
Health Research Council and the non
strategy stakeholders such as the chorus
resident Association the proposal has
been informed and has evolved by
Sumerian process but we accept all needs
to be done as the steps that I recent
meeting with my strengths and Essex Play
services design lobster we wish to work
closely to directly and positively
address these concerns relate
to urban design I love to that page 6.17
of the opposite reports close to a
letter dated eight to nine for this
people introduced which will externally
to the ground aspirin by the way these
matters which were addressed by the same
committee on the 25th of May we could
wait for them to the envy of what we met
on the 10th of May and where I respected
being legally obliged really lost
instructs and both house in this five
times table at the Lobo Van Pelt and bus
they by approves and every treaty was a
limit before blowing the waters Lane
will betroth roundabout to the South
hastily to the define effective
occupation of odd words as members will
call the violent part additional things
at the same time connecting that may be
considered that the only funds do not
believe a parent reserve masters
applications my email to MP confirms
this police and the matter was
successfully concluded noteworthy that
no objection it be paid by decency
highways the impacts of iboga lino
highways and the computation was
considered acceptable
consent further GCC flood west and water
management [ __ ] refuse the flow best
assessments and the service bulletin
very new strategy and brings no
objection
likewise no objections have been
received from ECC Archaeology in for
some good news
what judicial councils having trusty
team also support a proposal on basis
that it will quote provide a good mix of
properties that meet the current having
these in the district this is echoed by
the preferred Housing Association later
early human the resident product who can
be refused water housing and put
excessive on the basic undersized post
and wish to deliver this much-needed
affordable housing for local people in
the opposite addendum which is knows
that that publishing our council races
intersection i've subjective some design
issues which we mentioned before
tonight's address you know I'm going
discussions with all parties staying
with the addendum given increasing
confirmations approval of the condition
divided the way comments on the Essex
pile of associations are no longer
recently proposed turning to his face
Sonny's it would be noted that unlike
recent approvals from half those
of all of this half builders in the
districts of leading the local area that
is the expressed condition on the
this consent exception being for
learning space Sanders in requirement
that 3% of the drawings are which are
accessible handedness me compiling the
principle of the bones established for
the constant of the Dom proposed and
therefore exactly effective we accept
that this is the right location for this
type of development it but we would like
to continue to work with all parties
including them to the public
the a homemade hash Council and of
course they play services ministries to
establish that the right homes are also
delivered in light of the qisas advice
on this matter and other matters
relating to design members are
respectfully asked to defer this
application thank you thank you
a third speaker this is final function
chairman of the hybrid residents
Association
I think so you have five minutes miss
miss page it
okay Richie thinks about the policy
making notes of all the issues we
services is 2013 now concluded eh you
stated it in your planning Webster's
reporter the dependence upon us was not
perceived were part of my pardesi
accepted a preserved meta application
but he submitted application for this
Charlie position 6 & 7 in published on
picked up on approval the state's
project any receive Atlantic application
but these conditions should be read and
approved in writing the OTC website
states pending consideration buffer zone
security screening for local property
facing the site was suggested the PDW
did not respond Malians Lane with the
port of Jesus is not acceptable
presently the road or use for our star
traffic and the course manager come
people for the residence at six design
guide suggests that the width must be
1.5 meters HR a suggested a temporary
Road be built to alleviate congestion be
informed as the ECC highways consider
the road satisfactory Muse multi-lane
improvements and cookies still surface
water collection
drainage dispersal and silage is needed
the fertile land in Georgia land is not
an improvement as the traffic turn right
anyway but the planning inspector
suggests that party cGCC discuss ways
the wide in this Lane to accept the
amount of traffic which would increase
perhaps to financial constraints are
restraining groomers bus stop he
proposed reducing the fusco proposed
further provision and structure
infrastructure Peter Bishop should
renewable deck
towards insisting interception which
requires central operating we're happy
to consult on funding issues ECC fund a
multi management's insists on compliance
with common law if the grander scheme
proposes to discharge in term of science
at each point downstream repairing
landowners have not been consulted
this is unacceptable the technician
pumps are not acceptable
health and safety rules the current
methods of delivery must comply the
service automation systems the boundary
line dividing operation abroad and
parish councils with two-thirds and
one-third properties located
respectively ECC request the boundary
lines should be retained we request an
informational counseling face collection
thunderous HRA I'm not convinced the
carcass is eliminated - farm site has a
large floodplain area all service water
drainage systems would have to comply
the Essex County comes with such schemes
for major motors fire services
firefighting prices position are not
acceptable on taxes or other ways
housing we objected to three-story
buildings on the grounds that they
separate the village from the existing
conurbation which are predominantly one
two-story buildings we have noted that
the number of us come to mean the
45-degree room below generally and some
banking into sight businesses of 1345
readers do not comply the insisted on
going existing telephone dictation most
hazardous community HRA request
proposals through
all of us they presented a health hazard
totally unacceptable they're allocating
boucle become deposit required before
Lewis Artemis age report that
opportunity was lost especially that we
feel they're beginning to feel
comfortable construction construction
down access to some really w-well uh
neighborhoods ensure that the seasoning
that's them six years access points
would not be the traffic for accessing
risk versus earlier decision here by the
public right away
pendulum balance ranges the size under
publication 18mm to fall for this
reported that the media that the RDC
agreed to its rule the story is against
the planning Milo's and should not do
they tolerate the press for the above
issues are being included for review sir
having considered all these sequence of
user will be agreed that in terms of
refusal and to add the important issues
pension I have stated among evaluate RDC
confidence and should refuse offer the
deferral of the unification this refusal
presents and ranchers need to find more
sensible alternatives and to take
consultation more seriously the
professional groups such as HRA HRA to
write out what you see in here is Sarah
that this chaos will run for longer the
6:00 news
thank you
[Applause]
business
it was discussion I said how many
questions face
so he manages
so Thank You chairman about wrinkles
much of what mr. Carlton says well
obviously five minutes is very important
between everything that we all feel the
air those residents will pour over this
site on most extensive notes and I'm not
really aware of what's being passed
place pretty as we have cleared the room
undrew there'll be a deferral or group
or refusal was that they were still
possible I've just made a few days which
I like the committee to be aware of
thank you I do agree with republished
eight Minh that is made and I really
feel that point during the office report
or basic wonderful rain traces this we
found to achieve is better than those
character eases circuitously into an
appearance with a sense of the place
that makes it unique to hold bridge I
feel that myself has met with the
developers and residents as has Ron
Colton and I feel that perhaps concerns
haven't being listened to but not really
been taken on board and I think that's
reflected in the officer's report I know
we will be first people detail within
the drainage I know this is something
was
I've not seen any orders to show how the
drainage system will deal with the
closure of the sluice gates into the
crouch the broken wall treat ing
sometimes action will feel I never liked
what I saw a fuzzy flows through to the
snow skates
I don't want from the development of
drains me so if there's a period of
downpour that we've endured even to the
robot and the drainage attenuation ponds
will also be draining on the integral
from rain which may have been a few days
before this would be curative and more
than would always be the case and I'm
not seeing that that's actually being
dealt with moving on to a story building
camera 14.2 on page six point four four
in space of the three historic buildings
were at second eyes around one position
this is my view it's not the case the
provisional three-story building so in
fact there was no traffic drop super
crystalline Holdrege there are none and
ninety three story buildings or a few
townhouses a Unity Center the bots
proposed on the highest ground at the
development would dominate the skyline
and be visible for miles around there's
a key country to
SBD to arrive 18.1 who states are all
protocol
benefit members and residents
purpose-built fatty schemes have the
potential to be tracking the immunity of
the area if they do not respect the
height part of the general spaciousness
of their surroundings for example three
or four storey accommodation will
usually be entirely inappropriate in an
area of single-family to a nicer place
here I'll just draw your attention that
we are repeatedly told as members that
have my wishes outline and reserve
maintenance fees for design layout and I
take three stories to be part of design
and layout
no sir as a member despite the fact only
what we've shown you now boy it's just
out like it's what is a suggestion and
that's what we've always been advised
and that's what I've been taking members
now I'm going now to the five properties
that have family of daughters I take on
all office the strengths has said but
they only come to Council policy which
is SPD to fronting cycle secretaries I
take the point that he's trying to make
the deeply tends to be legitimate
everything is indicative that this is a
an off-the-shelf plan if you like it's
not full power property in home this is
just another example of something which
would be taken off the shelf on bulk and
stuck in that space which it wasn't
meant for we've come to the floor spaces
which is too pretentious bit and the
reason mainly would appear the deferral
it is not a small amount floor spaces
are seventeen property types do not mean
national space standards I would just
add that despite claims by the
developers it is not part to be on our
permission
it may not be especially being mentioned
space standards were raised by officers
in their report to the 22nd of March
2016 paragraph four point five three on
paragraph six point on page six point
five eight where it means very safe
ability so I'd be expecting to meet them
it was mentioned in the Republican Party
although it wasn't meant to do
report and all the members I believe
would have agreed before the basis that
those states based then is really report
on to social housing of injured space
their general observation the majority
of the social policy designer actually
the reason why they the space named
sidewalk
searching all visit social housing about
to meet space standards Republic the
special housing itself is not pet apatit
informative policy please maintain a
three-story blocks plus some house types
which are clustered together rather than
pet important in addition social housing
is first continue blindly says in the
report to contain divide our social
housing on this site is off is up one
would be oral particular types the
social housing type property types are
only used in social powers in terms
none of the social pounding rocky types
will be seeking private sales therefore
I cannot see that they are tending your
blind be just is impossible amenity
space
I think it's been making the obvious
report and it was declared an acceptable
but as a failure to provide adequate
space from block comprising Eunice three
one eight two three Thursday this
majestical because it's close to going
from space this is acceptable but this
is a block upon a typical flat it there
lutely beyond children there and it
seems that they can't they enjoy the
open space there's no privacy for them
so I think this is a bit a clear problem
for this book yes there's open space but
there should be an amenity space
specific for the people's living in that
log moving or not I do not agree that
the bounty treatment is good enough with
the possible removal offhandedly won't
bring space between the end of their
garden to the new development even
though it's provided the distance system
actually is not worth noting is about 25
weeks exams etc but actually is the
length of the garden
what's a new cast garden but maybe not
the house till the fall I want to say
that did it is previously being
discussed that when the original
application was being ported again that
there was an indication that perhaps the
part of being moved between the new
development and the development home
bridge to provide a baby for all that
hasn't happened or not the space should
be increased as I said to try meet all
the issues I have to take some time I
think of yoga but yet I do not want to
repeat while the people said such as mr.
McCarney they're not vendors thank you
[Applause]
I'd like you to draw your attention to
the report and pay 6.43
one a lot all right great
issue of the university currently the
development is bound by the same class
each week which puts the skate park on
the site however it is stated that the
office of the fine discussion with I
would like the discussion to also
include wool Cantor's who haven't
representation to young people or what
is actually wanted the reason I'm raised
is because the developers do not want
any on that side now in 2013 this
council went out and they asked young
people's what they wanted on that site
what allows always the skate park and
the developers are saying they don't
want no new facilities on that site so
chairman could you just explain does
that mean depending on that site
there's one thing I want to bring up
understand the emphasis a recommendation
to defer but I do have some very strong
concerns regarding providing a bride
away within the site we had this
application come before us a while ago
when we asked about throwing away the
attention it was projected I do feel
very strongly that we had others we had
cyclists and we have even move on horses
and I feel very strongly in it and then
on the addendum where it says our
response related product primarily up to
the application to remove the condition
to provide a boat like in started
prescribed by the permission and it said
we strongly we strongly objected the
removable
mission and I would like when this goes
to the offices and look at this I'd like
the officer to look at this with the
label go some homes once a day to
provide some sort of a faraway cyclist
and for the walkers within this within
this area
take chef Justin points para think
meeting an into my additional the other
one was the the applicant not be a
blockage to provide the bridal bridal
path condition to the consent if you
report also the Highways Authority
specifically objected to that members
debated them and then following a vote
the application to remove the condition
was approved
so now as part of the planning
Louisville that condition is no longer
before the applicants are compliant say
members considered the issues they had
the advice of the Highway Authority they
took a vote and
and that is a matter of record now the
applicant is no longer have supplying
that condition take a check
listen listen strongly to the option
I'll pick up on the private way side
things I think the develop mobile agent
here this evening go to here on Orthodox
of concerns and issues that every white
raised for our mentees and although it's
not a condition of the application and
has been the roof of the previous one I
still think there's perhaps immoral
suggestion that perhaps they should
reconsider
I for example is a perfect words today
and they've always there is footpaths
there is a golf course there is cycle
ways all within that area with very
minimal maintenance
and I don't see why that that couldn't
possibly be the same game yourself so
called upon the development of
preference in about I think there is an
opportunity I think the developments as
another member has already mentioned is
perhaps of health the pig style
development and slaughter need it needs
an awful lot of work to come back to us
which I'd be happy to agree to it
there's an awful lot of bits and pieces
some of it is quite minor some of it is
more serious but I think they need to
take this opportunity that's going to be
given to them to work the parish to work
with the residents association work with
the district council to make this a real
premier site right across the hall a
little bit there's an opportunity there
[Applause]
like a check obviously I've got lots of
fun issues around this I'm not sure
maybe people need to be given at one or
Sabean's
albeit ranches with the class mr.
strengthens to explain if the
the decision was for refusal without
taking legal advice what would be the
effect on potentially affected and
related to that and what I'd like to do
to seniors Sjogren's from campus
officers that we would instruct Queen's
Counsel as the developers because of the
equipment I spoke to this road and I
know that we don't actually employee
keepsake so for children's that we would
spend the money to do dealing with the
second question first that has been
talked about takes to count so that
dealing with more serious point
refused without taking that advice if it
comes to that
it's not uncommon for councils and
developers to battle over refuse
plantations the buzzer to us but the
appeal system looks at how reasonable in
the world in which in your decision
right particularly women behave
discipline they bring to that behavior
it costs and none of us have got a
crystal ball it's quite likely as the
applicant has offered an opportunity to
get think about the design revisions but
they've offered an opportunity to both
offices and members to rethink the
advice that review on the application of
the space vendors and it provided
account sales advice that's very serious
in its own right
and they've given us an opportunity to
throw the application to run council I
certainly think
running back if you didn't do so you can
take that opportunity and she decided
perhaps tonight no more issues on spice
or something the developer would have to
go into an appeal to defend their
position and if an inspector finds that
the counsel would have avoided that
aspect of it up here or having sorted
some device taking the opportunity then
that element of the appeal would have
been unreasonable it gets a little bit
worse perhaps the the inspector could
actually agree me perhaps at the end of
the duck and refused permission but he
could costs against incorrect in behaved
unreasonably and I'm trying to sort it
out so that's why we're saying to you
that there's an opportunities afforded
by the a little bit late in the w to
make for us to give it the consideration
it deserves and then by deferring we
could go away possibly get our own
counsel but most definitely
background so it's a mysterious fight
coming on it's a bit of an expert on
space standards but it will put you in a
better position when this application
returns whatever recommendation we give
you whether we stick with that side of
the recommendation if you miss your
rights or whether we find the need to
revise their advice to me at the moment
I'm slightly unnerved and I think it's
worth deferring the application so make
sure you have the quality advice that
thanks Mike yeah I probably even
anything further this station obviously
is something we need to take away and
research but I would only say the the
moment the council's position is as it
was the sakes that underlie obviously
needs and we would prefer to go away and
research it and take new counsel if
necessary
and you know check those what Isis pick
up points have been made by hopeless
residents association and cancer my boy
oh and also from the Americans as well
which is the buffer buffer for the
properties that boundaries on the side
and it seems to me that these we can
consistently apply so some properties
but much less awful nervous and what I
propose is that actually even with the
property to have the same buffer and not
only that but to extend it up to her to
some gardens and to open topic gardens
as well which that's the first thing
then the next point relates to boundary
issues raised by mr. Cobb and now I know
that within planning you can actually do
get permission for developments across
boundaries the questionnaire about mode
is how they aid integration we've got
one half of the community in both
attacks Council and the other half in
publish council it's the book with the
integration now that's actually a work
Thank You chairman I'll deal with the
other issues first though just ask
members to ponder actually questions
made the same but I'm fearful of a
regimented set with arising from that
request just ask members to consider
that probably attraction of the buffer
that's in various widths and then I
breathe it may be an absence of in some
parts but if you had if you had a
mandatory whimpers of barking you would
end up with quite a regimental fixed
position part of the attraction of the
varying buffer we assume that so take
the point that make improvements on the
sides but I'll just what members to be
clear are members asking for a stating
dimension or are they allowing some
artistic license from the landscapers to
provide an attractive landscape age by
virtue of their ascending naturalised
different series by a human being better
and if that's the way members got
the boundary area there are probably
many parishes that I had afraid his
house was on two boundaries we used to
go to his lounge in Stonebridge and we
used to go to his kitchen Roger you
don't you don't have the ocean between
communities by by physical physical
boundaries it sometimes happens that
there is a clear mind it is a road or
railway line or something between people
but a lot of these parish boundaries
would like to church tides and things
I'm a long time come he is in his
everyday urban authorities I've sat in
the Town Council boundary in the
district they merge and you can't know
where they are people go about their
lives and services and things and they
don't know where the bound result they
don't knit it's a little bit different
practical districts and cities where
there's a bit more of a geographic
relationship norwich the extreme in the
middle of nowhere but i think it members
are concerns that there should be a
delineation in this way out up here
somewhere whether the roar of parish
boundaries we probably need a physical
division and i'm not sure what purpose
if you want integration these i think
the idea is the people on this develop
would really like to help reach their
goods and services but if they find that
they live in you know in the parish you
kind of preset parish that's a matter to
them I get it that these people are on
the edge of that parish but I think it
would be a mistake if we're looking to
try and draw a boundary through here so
just to separate those those two areas I
mean my planning point of view it was
not the integrated
just because I didn't actually bring
that they should be about what I'm
saying is if there are in two separate
parishes it's difficult to get that to
be integrated move on to one exit like I
can check
paragraph four point five nine page six
point nine six and this is where the
Essex Police favor to me to really
design and I'm glad I got to know that
could be six there's only ten when it
ends the person gardens and a precise on
you take visitor spaces in the location
for twenty five twenty and then G or the
wrists I say here is that because of the
lack of parking perhaps motivated to the
side and might actually spit out on
existing residential areas of course
country and what would say it's one of
the one of the biggest issues and
councillors face is to do the parking
finally it's tuna sushi three-story
buildings has been mentioned in general
but said there were three blocks that
I've mentioned lots mentioned
specifically the ones 350 two three five
eight three eight three two three nine
one and three nine eight two three
these are herbs at 4:06
if you look they're actually very close
to each other we're actually on the
highest audit in Holdrege so full
Louisville Road which is roughly
exceeded the slope greatly incomes up to
20 meters above sea level and that's how
the petitioners about 600 meters so that
as it's been said before the first thing
that people were sitting dominate the
skyline of the three storey blocks of
flats and Dave as we mentioned you
thought this isn't actually keeping the
public so what the dudes were creating
something very unique but not
necessarily something that's actually
very attractive and then finally unit
4.6 to look at these armies this is a
two and a half story building that pops
up to number 18 Hansa Gardens and this
seems to be country to the Essex is on
the right and also to their policy to
the m1 and dm3
because if you do it draws the existing
property and is actually very close so
that's that's right
they'd say well all spruced up question
this is Kristen
thank you before I comment on what these
are project making report and has been
quite a lengthy debate I'd like to ask
three questions of the offices if I may
the first one relates to the roundabouts
or sea miles of where to be superseded
but I do have concern my experience is
such that in when these restrictions
were built at 200 in the reports of the
build in the verbal report be receptive
occupation and my experience is that
that comes under the section 106 and it
can be denied now I would like the
officer to advise if there is a more
objective method rather than occupation
to determine when that should take place
and also some care should be given to
the time it will take to implement that
roundabout it will be out probably
imagine a matter of weeks if not months
and therefore I think of 200 houses
having been built
I mean bill put do that they make to the
main air tonight do then they alter
tighten that make occupy do that make
the foundations it's not clear I think
we need a great deal of clarity and I
think they all would that clarity should
be in the conditions because it hasn't
been my experience in the past say it
has so chemic we don't want but more
specific arrangement is my question
Jim the couldn't do that with this
application now because all the triggers
and the definitions are in the outline
plenty of the agreements our mind
language
to help Memphis I don't know it is
familiar with it made predating
so you may not be aware of that and it
says occupancy that would be a trigger I
prefer it's like the member said if
you're dealing with foundations when it
has a roof for drainage connecting you
know when when to those things happened
if you've got somebody who has moved in
on a Monday morning
that is occupancy that's what we mean by
the occupancy so it's quite typical for
legal agreements afraid I haven't got to
hand the precise definitions of the one
used in this agreement on this outline
but if they've used occupancy I would
expect private sale they take
you might as brilliant as ever all right
can we just ask that is idea to have
noticed it in the past
thank you the second question Enrico
asked the surface water drainage and the
attendant attenuation box I think other
members won't be surprised to know that
I'm not the favorite of these I prefer
thank you I am concerned on this is in
the department we unplug pond is tapped
away and just from a point of safety
water attracts children children don't
necessarily swim and pumps tend to get
very young Bobby it wasn't
I wonder what safety provisions will be
made for that period
with science in the kitchen
I don't have that details fact and as
this is a detailed application I think
you could have a condition
anyway the boat goes
proving that you could put a condition
on these details
to have that man sir as a member of
further consideration or microplane
condition the details for think about
any fencing things like these students
at Sears being provided the only thing I
would be slightly wear on what normally
happens with these sons their their
shallow areas are no sitting around in a
cup of tea the idea is they are not
deemed pits that they depressions in the
main scope so that yes they feel the
appearance of Esav excessive right
erotic they act as a as a public either
spicy but fences trend rather frustrates
me it may well be the applicants
introduce measures achieve both things
now if he was looking at a planning
consent that this detail stage didn't
feel that was covered in an institution
those measures
thank you and I'm sorry two strikes I'm
asking lots of questions that clear
before I determine my view of this last
but not least page six point four two
point ten this muscle misheard this
reproducibly play every to be reduced by
15% and he says no points it check and
its most potent I believe from the
lesson we had today from The Residents
Association underneath the 15% the snare
calculation when I was advising members
there for you in the submission date
today
thank you so much information right
thank you
the first thing about slate my
experience to see another recommendation
Luigi remembers it if at all when that
raises possible concern in itself but
the application is in such a situation
with the offices have felt the need to
do that
having said that on all I seen heard I
think they've been very kind because
they'd be if the information looks like
you should be pleased but deferment we
have been advised by offices and I think
offices have got the ability to
hopefully sort this out with all member
resistance and develop that but what we
might have to consider is that this is a
lots that reflect we know we're losing
it but what we should be seeing is a
very good discipline we should have the
best possible result when we are losing
rebound
we shouldn't have has been described as
the off the peg situation that fall
short on so many of the situations
and it does the knuckle pepper potty and
the lack of tenure grind is obviously a
concern since then and I want to I won't
go into that strongly I'm surprised that
the officers said that where women
reflect encourage that SP Dean's who
that works that when there's no strong
character existing but there's nothing
existing there so there is no excuse for
developers putting a trope dormers
because they're not complying with
anything the whole design is in their
game turning to the report on domains
going through Ebates out i'm just
highlighted issues and i'll go through
well details concerned concerned
shouldn't be missed opportunity to debts
causes concern to pedestrian safety area
is revisited again relaxed passive
surveillance previously concern I mean
there are some positives don't get me
wrong but they're heavily outweighed by
the negatives and
certainly I would support any one for
deferment that gets this application
into a state where hopefully
no positive way as it stands in
certainly not acceptable with lots of
arrows with real experience
[Applause]
one more question Thank You chairman um
the open design concern would they
possibly be addressed by units that were
larger or additional housing units
coming in
then woke up this
I think we'd like to give the effort the
opportunity to consider all
possibilities what I can tell you is
that one of the thoughts is about
changing some of the siting in the form
of the buildings like being get frontage
here on the present they were needed to
either add to that building but
extension under parking will complete
the frontage with attractive
articulation which may in turn our
substitution of buildings that they they
want the opportunity to consider that
but there is also with all the existing
number of dwellings you've got is to
reinforce the character to not only
changing the to the person the way
they're used in some diversity so so I
would expect you to see a number of
small solutions that might add up to a
far better and greater hub as well as
possibly the change of some some
buildings the applicant basically what's
the opportunity to go and think about
now they're here listening to your views
tonight to the web so they'll have their
own ideas
the ideas the officers of my colleagues
have left they also give this debugging
and they'll know make of that what they
will assume a lot to think they see what
they can do
thank you I have to other briefly to all
sweetness and light no doubt that when
he speaks this evening I'm concerned
about three-story buildings and what's
the status of the farmhouse is that
they're not compared to Ali
the bomb has a fairly recently the
farmhouse is unoccupied it's it's got
like security fencing around into some
vandalism etc as far as another bungalow
he's occupied recently it was doing
supplies there loves the status of it
they call
Thank You non-designated heritage assets
those automatically should be a great
three mr. builders so it doesn't have
protection it's not perhaps worthy of
protection may be nice to keep it we
could now this is development but
knowledge is that thing Ricky farm has
to keep some of the setting of the
surroundings it so true that they could
if they want to impress them not to over
it to be in a great shape their chose to
keep that as part of this scheme and
I've seen these developers do that
elsewhere not house is nice but they've
kept sometimes a pair of Sammy's on the
street frontage little part of the site
that they then renovated doing okay and
that's probably what they look at that
building I believe they they probably
own that and you've seen their ownership
so no this is quite nice setting for
somebody to Victor today so I think we
luckily this coaster there's no plans in
motion
thank you very much
accumulative so some questions for
strength
in relation to the revised
recommendation
actually got to isomers this is the
reason
now is it the case that we
comes back to
in
to discuss matters in relation to those
specific titular aspects because they
Department decision
if that is the case there's been a
number of discussion may not necessarily
be covered by that
would they need to be handed in as
additional reasons to determine so that
heat much makes it much longer
yes maybe she'll definitely be more
clinical analysis although writing
things I'm sure the applicants i18n is
through members be absolutely clear this
is the Masters addition to the officers
recommendation others things like this
members could itemize those to help us
give us a shopping list to go back to
Hamilton I can't promise to degree on
all of those with the applicant that
will take the view on that but we have a
starting list at least and the
applicants were purple since night that
would be very good to work so I would
definitely prefer that it was right in
to give us a list of things
that's this time we've got notes they
say we'll come back view is workable
right you can listen to us
the item so there's not a big easy
question susceptor that jet I was going
to move the furnace but what I would
suggest is that the applicants those way
has a listen to the recording that picks
up one person or amount has been
discussed for picking up on strengths
point there of the number of things that
you would add to it
can I suggest chair that now our group
deferment for a second that perhaps each
counselor in terms of members members
gives mr. shanks resume a of the items
that they actually
[Music]
thank you thank you I really like start
with reconsidering the by the way and
the facilities there the thought that
struck me make they mr. change was
talking about the farmhouse there it
looks like quite substantial building
and it looks like this and look at
buildings there the thought that struck
me was the perhaps some youth facilities
could be incorporated within that
context it's indoor sexual thought to it
to me but German I would suggest that
think to make that actually gives mr.
train service
check it sir echo why do I think
essentially please
my things and yet certainly usual
ex-members so they're public and I think
that should be the world
the local parish council Emily the
action group is gonna need coverage on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
this homicide and yes I will agree to
determine who will listen to the points
raised talk to our officers and ward
councillors to try and get it sorted out
you know I'm regretful ignorant of our
immediate environment alone you know
building research establishment other
people that have established this kind
of thing it's and the residents
Association report when most
professional ones are their decision yes
so that this comes consultation this is
a brilliant idea
and I have no objections to private
parts I think they say every is just
kind of made for them it's just it's
such a popular pastime so if they they
can give a consideration to that but
also you want somewhere we're just going
to be pleasantly and walking around and
people think give it a wow factor and it
has not got that this with members here
with regardless that once race this
evening parity council and also the
members from the public I would actually
I grew in my photo council so we have to
go too much about trees and shrubs just
good for the environment pollution
perhaps even if it tips of the trees
and 1.12 big trees as well thank you
Beckerman of my main concern is the
urban design factor and the room sizes
inside the properties themselves thank
you Kay oh I'll give you a list of some
that I've noted as we've been discussing
I'm sure that the recording and the
strikes were picked up most of them but
boo me why this is going to be hopefully
community not just a housing estate is a
community for future so the three-story
buildings I think under sets bullet
principle there's nothing locally that
makes that sound like that consideration
the pepper pottery is against Ackroyd
lines is not turn your blind as has been
pointed out so that's something that
needs to be addressed because we're
talking about communities who don't want
to revile with their nasty direct and I
do understand the demands of setting as
opposed to anything else but we're
talking about it
so safety proposal would I like to see
included the cold dominated layout needs
to be reassessed the amount of visitor
parking needs to be addressed
the inclusion of a skatepark needs to be
considered the amenity areas for the
Brooks
you need to have specific community
areas and hopefully some drawing areas
as well buffer zones between the
development and the existing buildings
need to be increased and the space
Sanders national suede Sanders should be
looked at as a minimum those are just a
few the same thing like maybe a Costa
Mesa you've got most of my hello no
sorry yeah just to clarify Buffett
smaller than the standard size just look
very should just be a minimum also I'm
paying for the police to be involved in
this in the design of the site so we can
get secured by design and then I won't
know anything the three stories but unit
full 6-4 6-2 which is the 2.4 I still in
structure back in on to 18,000 are and
also plot 303 which is a three story
building back in a moment
we should look at those in relation to
how they fit with existing properties
[Applause]
that said they've also got so much - and
when surprised people that I would back
all development and my main concerns
around the body and the positioning of
the three-story buildings and the
episodes for housing also concerns me
Rosen supreme at the right away
introduced cycle paths
[Applause]
other councils the only thing that may
be obviously mentioned such as party
addendum there was
which historians and transpiration
advice and that related to orbits
mentioned just recently to do with the
farm building and there was some gift
suggestions in there about how the
surrounding that
on the plan what he improved to make
i benefit movies on nothing perhaps that
no commitments we've had cookie bites
hopefully members did or hopefully made
clear to members about the bridle-path I
will take that away and ask the
advocates I hope absolutely just say on
the skate park the legal agreements to
the minor permission ask the applicant
obligated the applicant to provide the
youth facilities and there was a number
of discussions at the time various
parties pulling in different directions
etc and the default position was if they
couldn't agree to provide a skate park
on the site now I believe the applicants
and the parish ahead by extensive
discussion about enhancing norms like
these things like now for table tennis
teen shelters other things as well as an
SSK Park but a lot better but the kid
practicing on bricks or thing I park
next to it I couldn't see religion
they've been worked on by the applicant
and the parish with a view to do this
and this is mr. under the framework of
the agreement to the outline consent if
they achieve those negotiations is there
in fulfillment of their obligation it's
only if they couldn't agree then it
would have to by default please take up
and provided on the site now they've
done someone to achieve in other
facilities elsewhere in discussion with
the parish so I can't promise that
members could expect the state partners
be provided on this site it was it was
the backstop in the provisions that were
being sought the applicants were given
150 grams worth of youth facilities to
provide and left to see what they come
up with negotiating the various interest
groups if they couldn't agree state park
that was had to be built one like what
they've got
possible innocence so hopefully that's
clear Joe we may find that the the
applicant is an advanced IT chip
negotiation with others for providing
stuff for the community to use of
knowledge Jerry do you wish me to
formally accept all those images my
composition which likely so do so and
I'm just like - I do
we're giving the developing here a
fantastic opportunity back